– Das haben Sie geschrieben?
Das ist super.
Haben Sie die Bewerbung
denn auch abgeschickt?
– Nein, der Text war nicht für eine
bestimmte Bewerbung,
sondern nur eine Übung
in meinem Sprachkurs.
– Dann wird es Zeit, dass wir die
Theorie in die Praxis umsetzen.
Sie haben jetzt hier
eine Aufenthaltserlaubnis.
Mit dieser Erlaubnis dürfen Sie
nicht nur in Deutschland wohnen,
sondern können hier auch
arbeiten oder studieren.
Sie haben die B1-Prüfung bestanden
und wie ich das hier so sehe,
ist B2 auch für Sie gar kein Problem.
Haben Sie schon mal über die
Möglichkeit nachgedacht, hier zu studieren?
– Ja, aber …
– Sie wissen nicht,
was Sie studieren möchten?
– Selma ist sehr gut mit Zahlen.
– Interessieren Sie sich
für ein technisches Fach?
– Eigentlich macht mir
kreative Arbeit mehr Spaß.
– Nun, es gibt viele Berufe,
in denen man nicht nur technisch
und mathematisch interessiert,
sondern auch kreativ sein muss.
Vielleicht interessieren Sie sich für
die Arbeit im Produktdesign
oder im Social-Media-Bereich.
Mein Vorschlag:
Bewerben Sie sich für ein
Praktikum in einer Firma.
Dann sehen Sie, ob Ihnen
die Arbeit Spaß macht, okay?
Ich such Ihnen mal etwas
Informationsmaterial raus.
– Danke, Mama.
– Bitte schön!